بين المشاكل الصحيه التي تخلقها السمنه
ومرض السكري الذي يقلب نمط حياه المرضى
وبين الناحيه الجماليه تبرز المعضله
دواء مرخص من هيئه الغذاء والدواء
الامريكيه تم استخدامه طوال سنوات لمرضى
السكري ينتشر اليوم في اوساط خساره الوزن
مع غياب الحديث عن الاثار الجانبيه لهم
الا ان استخدام الدواء لم يتوقف عند
الاشخاص الذين يعانون من السمنه المفرطه
فحسب بل اتجه بعض من المشاهير الى
استخدامه لخساره اوزان بسيطه ونتيجه لذلك
استطاع هذا الدواء الانتشار بشكل واسع على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ليصبح وسيره سهله
لكن مكلفه لخساره بضعه كيلو جرامات زائده
قد تذهب بالحميه والتمارين الرياضيه بعيدا
عن حالات السمنه المفرطه المستعصيه التي
تعرض حياه اصحابها للخطر الاقبال على هذا
الدواء المكلف ماديا اصلا ادى الى نقصه في
الاسواق بالتزامن مع حاجه مرضى السكر اليه
ليحتج العديد من المرضى والاطباء على
ترتيب الاولويه استخدام الدواء وافضليته
لمرضى السكري تحت اسماء تجاريه عده وماده
فعاله اساسيه هي سيماجلوتايد الدواء ذاته
يعمل على ناحيتين اساسيتين الاولى هي
تحفيز البنكرياس لافراز الانسولين المسؤول
عن تنظيم سكر الدم اما الثانيه فهي تحفيز
الهرمونات التي تؤدي الى الشعور بالشبع
وتعطي اعازا بامتلاء المعده حتى مع كميات
الطعام القليله ما يؤدي لتقليل الشهيه الا
انه لا يخلو من الاعراض الجانبيه الهضميه
بشكل اساسي منها الغثيان والقيء والاسهال